[Music]
how did they get the feather to
cooperate like that and for so long this
is a bus stomp right because that bus
stops for barely a full second before
moving on without even seeing it force
wants to get on I know he's sitting
there like a Gump on a log but at least
do a verbal track he's literally waiting
at the bus stop bitch my mom always said
life was like a box of chocolates you
never know what you're going to get so
deep so profound so meaningless
seriously it's much credit as this movie
gets for its notable quotable so the
sentiments are so bland as to not
actually mean much at all each quote is
a bit different but ultimately at their
core contain the same syrupy sweet empty
calories that makes you feel good for a
moment but do nothing to make you
stronger overall you know like a box of
chocolates I bet if I think about it
real hard I could remember my first pair
of shoes she said they was my magic shoe
so yeah apparently according to the
movie Forrest was about seven years old
before we ever got a pair of shoes yeah
he needed special braces but the movie
suggesting his mother only ever puts
socks on his feet up until this moment
and that's just a lot oh now when I was
advising mama named me after the great
Civil War hero force narration for
station he started up this club called
the Ku Klux Klan
yes let's address racism with a
light-hearted simple misunderstanding of
a childlike adults will be basically
points of things and says look that
exists and then just moves on like it
did something important he's gonna have
to go to special school if something can
be done my own mama sure does care about
your school inside prostitue ish it
vacation we're dead and we aren't
vacations when you go somewhere and you
don't ever come back
can we all just agree that the fact that
Forrest didn't grow up to be a murderous
psycho is a goddamn miracle some years
later that handsome young man who they
called the Kay
had himself a heart attack or something
or something like this movie wants to
bully so hard that this little cur said
seats taken
even though there wasn't a seat
available there let's see already has
two riders can't see yeah quite a while
these Alabama kids hate the new kids so
much I don't even think half of these
fools even saw his leg braces they're
just bullying him by default can Alabama
man ladies and gentlemen the
romantically forced very clearly takes a
rock to the eye here but for some reason
bleeds from his forehead for the record
these bully straight up stoning Forrest
are also trespassing this movie Road
Runners hard y'all like a comical amount
he was a very loving man he was always
kissing and touching her and her sisters
it's impossible Forrest Gump was the
most offensive movie ever made I'm
asking because I think for Scott maybe
the most offensive movie ever made
I implore you to keep running now and
pray later ten years and these bullies
haven't upgraded from rock throwing lazy
bullies are lazy the truck goes from
inches away from hitting Forrest to
forty feet behind it and this movie won
the Oscar for best film editing coldly
now it used to be I ran to get while is
going since we are entering minute 20 of
this Ventura narration I think it's safe
to say this is basically gonna play out
like a book on tape from here on out so
let's just throw on 15 narration is as
narration does sins and move on shall we
[Applause]
wow this movie utterly delights and
forced mental capacity plays it for
jokes and everything even while wanting
to use it for sympathy whenever
necessary
welcome to we've edited Tom Hanks and do
all the historical events and hey isn't
that cool the movie this film wants you
to know it's the kind of movie that will
go directly from Tom Hanks drying his
junk tis showing an actual shooting in
mere seconds with a level of whiplash
going on I'm surprised JK Simmons and
miles teller haven't shown up so Forrest
Gump shows up at a college unannounced
sees her in a car with a boy and decides
the boy is too aggressive and maybe the
boy was and then Forrest intervenes
which angers Jenny and scares off the
boyfriend and I have written a dozen
versions of the sin about force being a
creepy stalker but I'm mostly baffled
that this still somehow ends up in him
getting a handjob considering we've
already seen George Wallace when the
school steps which happened in June of
1963 and the all-american team is chosen
in December there was no way force could
have met JFK here when he had already
been assassinated the month prior now
the really good
thing about meeting the President of the
United States is the food it's true
pepper the hamburgers are fabulous
I must have drive me about 15 dr.
peppers not physically possible 15 dr.
pepper 20 ounce bottles is 300 fluid
ounces which equals 8 point 8 liters get
the average human bladder reaches
capacity at just over half a liter my
point is he could have been peeing the
entire time he was in the White House
and it's still mathematically impossible
for him to have drugged 15 dr. peppers
also dr. pepper someday soon when deep
fakes have ruined our ability to trust
anything we see and sent our world into
a fiery Armageddon can we please
remember it was Robert Zemeckis who led
us there after only 5 years of playing
football I got a college degree the NCAA
tight tight the scene is meant to echo
that earlier scene he was a child and
everyone on the bus hated him but Jenny
and I'd like to accept it but there was
no reason given why folks on this bus
would shun or hate forests they don't
know anything about it at all mines for
scum people call me Forrest Gump I'm not
a smart man but I know a roll credits
alone when I see one
not time then the army is a lonely time
you can take either nighttime or in the
army out of that statement and it's
still true that is the most obvious W
being used upside-down in place of an M
I have ever seen there's no microphone
and no amp or speakers or monitors with
stage show either routinely has audio or
it's a live for a movie scene Forrest
acting like he is Jenny's bodyguard and
sole protector is kind of something
issed right she's even yelling for us
let me down right here if she wants to
sing naked golf Forrest I loved you
Forrest you don't know what love is
I'd give back a dozen sins if you break
into song right here Oh No Liz why does
the army send new soldiers to the
frontlines via helicopter and two at a
time
it seems like a huge waste of gas and
time and money and gas now I don't know
much about anything Forrest is still
telling the story on the bus stop bitch
right so why is he whispering all of a
sudden little bit of stain gang right
and big all fat range
I flew in sideways after sitting through
the types of shrimp and now the types of
rain I'm beginning to think they added a
half hour to the runtime just by listing
things well this is BuzzFeed hi folks
all the shrimp you can eat
Red Lobster called they'd like you to
stop using their main form with employee
recruitment looking for a big getting
ladder from I just as soon she had Jenny
gives 0 it's about forest all moving
long until the end she's dying and
desperate Jenny is the worst man I mean
the movie could easily have been
subtitled he survives this and this and
this and this this is exile Ridge 20
years before Hacksaw rich he just keeps
going back to rescue more and more dudes
regardless of his own safety
I moved but then I remember I'm in an
extended Billy Joel's we didn't start
the fire music video and pilot and all
go gliding down the river of dreams
that's all I had to say about that so
we're done then the only good thing
about being wounded in the buttocks is
the ice cream damn it
I know Greenbow Alabama is a fake town
and all but does it have two different
zip codes sure he could have
accidentally wrote the wrong numbers but
I'm guessing that's an error in the
continuity Department would be more
likely to make them forest not a secret
to this game is never ever take guy off
the book is mostly played for laughs
here but in this ping-pong advise moment
he takes it to heart and it's adorably
hilarious I choose this as the moment I
will remove once it Julis animation we
all have a destiny nothing just happens
it's all part of a plan Gary Sinise is
absolutely killing it here the problem
is that he isn't our protagonist and
he's barely in the movie instead we're
stuck with a protagonist who was a
glorified narrator and an unreliable one
at that Hanks is fine but he exists
around the moments of the movie but
never really engaged in them leaving me
uninterested and just wishing I had seen
the lieutenant dam movie instead where
were you hit in the buttocks like she
did I miss the part in history class
about LBJ being a creepy perv the hell
earlier The News said LBJ was giving out
more medals of honor
President Johnson awarded four medals of
Honor to men from each of the Armed
Services why do I count five with go
this dudes middle name better be
coincidence or else I'm gonna kill a
bunny there was only one thing I could
say about the war on Vietnam there's
only one thing I could say about the war
in Vietnam movie is almost two and a
half hours long and this is wrong
with an event this big are we really
saying the sound situation was a set it
and forget it kind of thing how it's no
one even watching the sound board that's
so right on me and character says
something compelling and extremely
meaningful but we can't hear it because
of reasons cliche he's chewing magnets
wherever he goes there she is it's
almost as though someone wrote their
lives as opposed to them happening
organically even the Washington Monument
is giving the one-finger salute to this
contrived and convenient reunion of the
pig brutalize rape our women I think
it's safe to say that nuance is not this
movie strong suit you should not be
hitting ugh the most important line in
the film is one of the most forgotten so
I had no your Black Panther Party thing
I said to Ryan Coogler after my feud
with Jeff Goldblum got physical and
somehow spilled over into a nearby
soundstage buddy wanna go to San
Francisco for drugs Forrest we have very
different lives you know yep he makes
smart choices and you keep you know why
are you so good to me
you're my girl I'll always be damn it
Jenny you do more for his betterment by
disappearing than continuing to show up
every few years in super coincidental
fashion to help keep his pipe dream of
being with you alive I got it just by
doing what you told me to do this is not
true not in a literal way and not even
in a simplistic forest way she told you
to run away when there was danger and
you most certainly did not do that in
fact it took three different people in
the moment to tell you to run before you
even started not to mention you
technically won the medal for saving the
lives of members of your unit and not
actually for running away but hey I got
a shoehorn in that running metaphor
right ping-pong proceeds to propaganda
proportions without properly petitioning
participants previous political
positions when I got home I was a
national celebrity
famouser Raven and Captain Kangaroo for
playing table tennis quick name one
great thing pong player in the history
of mankind exactly in the land of China
people hardly got nothing at all no
possessions I don't have the time to
show you the entire setup and punchline
and the rest of this manufactured
nonsense but basically through questions
and answers Forrest Gump helps write
Lennon's Imagine because nothing is
sacred in this movie that wants to be
profound and ends up feeling more like
one cheap SNL sketch after another not
using the crosswalk in a city this big
on a street this busy in icy snowy
conditions is worth five kinks
the selfishness is through the roof and
they found Jesus yet no in this movie
I'm sure we'll find out that the Sermon
on the Mount was actually about how
Christ appreciated all of Gump's
attributes and wanted to pass them on
it's not all everybody gets a second
chance
well unless you're famous when your
chances are virtually unlimited Rasta
taunts look sometimes companies go
overboard and pitching potential
spokespeople but this is a lie no one is
making multiple standees and Gump
branded paddles of this number on the
hope he agrees to son
everybody knows who the true but mom
says just a little white lie so wouldn't
hurt nobody
advertising in a nutshell fishing
lowercase e is going to hunt so many
people myself included force boat
survives this seriously there's more
suspension of disbelief that has to
happen in this one movie and the entire
Marvel Cinematic Universe combined I
haven't seen someone look this out of
place with a gospel choir since halftime
of Super Bowl 53 right then God showed
equating the weather with God's will I
never thanked you for saving my life
still haven't but at that time and the
house was all empty
I had always think of Jenny are we
supposed to be rooting for this love
story it just seems like a bad idea on
so many levels and if not what are we
supposed to be rooting for Gump's
basically just accidentally himself into
being a famous millionaire time and time
again I just don't know why I'm supposed
to care about any of this and then she
was that it's almost like the script
itself has given up on coming up with
reasons things are happening the
screenplay is sitting in the corner
smoking a cigarette saying I've had
enough you just fill in whatever blanks
you want and then she was there is about
the best I've got left in me
Jenny came back and stayed with me maybe
it was because she had no or else to go
or maybe it's just how co-dependent
relationships work sometimes I guess
there just aren't enough rocks like the
rest of the movie this line isn't half
as deep as it wants you to think it is
it actually doesn't even make any sense
she told him she wouldn't marry him and
hurt his feelings
now hours later she's gonna sleep with
him Jenny is an awful human being in
this movie alright and then she leaves
I'm never gonna be team Jenny get it
because she said running and that's the
theme of the movie that automatically
makes it super intelligent I swear this
movie is all chicken soup and no soul
and he just left his front door open and
no
squatted or looted or anything over the
next however many years of him running
probably the hardest to believe thing in
this entire movie honestly as much press
as Gump has gotten from his ping-pong
medal of honor shrimping business and
this run is it really possible that he
could sit on a public bench and not be
recognized by someone at this point this
whole forest runs for a few years part
it's just worthless yeah yeah run
Forrest run and all that but there's no
real point of this he doesn't meet
anyone dozen really grow as a person
they literally needed something for him
to do for a few years before he gets to
come pet to Jenny again have a nice day
well some years later I found out that
that man did come up with an idea for a
t-shirt no uh-uh
yeah we've been through four presidents
since the Watergate scene and gum has an
age today fake newspaper article
headline accidentally sums up everything
I've been thinking for the last two
hours perfectly also in Jenny's
scrapbook of forest clippings as she
called them there's an Enquirer headline
go-go dancer says Forrest Gump made me
his secret lover and you will never
convince me Jenny herself didn't give
the interview that led to this story
during a time which you need to cash
probably for drugs ah baby Joel Osment I
have some kind of virus and the doctors
don't I don't know what it is she means
AIDS right this movie is just the kind
of movie to maybe sort of want to make a
reference to AIDS but also wants to pull
its punch so it doesn't offend kind of
like how they never want to talk about
for its actual diagnosis or condition
it's just slow stupid not smart let the
audience draw their own conclusions I'll
take care of you sick would you marry me
what the literally of the last scene she
told him he was a father and said
there's nothing you need to do now she's
proposing to him even when she's trying
to do something good Jenny makes
terrible decisions not one of these
prick bastards gave up their seat for
the guy with the prosthetic legs or even
walked over there to the left and grab
one of those black patio chairs for him
to sit in he's kind of stay on the
entire ceremony as it when the Sun comes
up I couldn't tell where and then stop
yeah the game this literally started a
few moments ago with her asking him were
you scared and Vietnam just FYI you died
on a Saturday morning except that
Jenny's tombstone says she died on March
22nd 1982 which was a Monday so suck on
that Gump I mean sorry for your loss had
you placed here under a tree I didn't
get any kind of cemetery permits or
nothing I'm not sure he combs his hair
brushes his teeth every day if this
movie were made today it would be about
some snooty
trying to take custody the child away
from Gump and him having to get a
scrappy lawyer to go to court and the
bitchy aunts lawyer would ask do you
seriously think you are fit to be that
child's father and Gump would proudly
respond no ma'am I am that child's
father she's so smart is he crying are
you crying there's no crying in gumball
seriously this is basically the only
emotion we've seen from Forrest the
entire movie but why now sure Jenny died
but so did his mom and most of his
military unit why is he suddenly an
emotional being when for the last 2
hours and 10 minutes he's basically been
the emotional equivalent of a parking
meter I don't know if we each have a
destiny or if we're all just floating
around accidental like on a brace maybe
it's both great so the movie's big
message is ultimately a double negative
everyone has a destiny and also no one
to us the end you want to see the most
beautiful thing I've ever filmed my name
is Barry Allen and I am the fastest man
alive guys don't
this is West oh my sweet Wesley what
have I done
this was my call must have been a tough
one quiet quiet he's gonna say something